מחשבים קוונטיים הם מנטור לבעיות שפשוט לא ניתן לפתור
עם מחשבים קלאסיים דברים
כמו למצוא את החומרים הנכונים כדי לאפשר
לכידת פחמן באמת
להוביל את המלחמה בשינויי האקלים, לטפל
בדשנים יעילים יותר שיכולים
לא לפגוע בכדור הארץ אבל גם להמשיך את
שרשרת אספקת המזון שאנחנו צריכים כדי להאכיל את העולם
בנוסף יש כמה שאלות בסיסיות על איך היקום שלנו
מורכב ואיך חומר מתנהג ברמה האטומית
ותת-האטומית שאנחנו צריכים לדעת
זה הגבול הבא
בואו ניקח תחום מחקר אחד שכבר בעיצומו
החיפוש אחר סוללות חדשות
סוללות שינו את חיינו בכך שאיפשרו לנו לשאת
מחשבים וסמארטפונים
אבל יש עוד מה לעשות סוללות הן קריטיות
לעתיד האנרגיה הנקייה שלנו
בין אם זה הנעת מכוניות חשמליות באמת
לדחוף קדימה אנרגיה מתחדשת
אנחנו צריכים כימיה שונה מהיסוד
כדי ליצור את הסוללות
של מחר מחשוב קוונטי
יאפשר לנו להסתכל בצורה אפקטיבית לתוך הסוללה
במהלך התגובות המורכבות מאוד שלה כדי לאפשר לנו
לחשוב על חומרים חדשים
ועל המבנה של הסוללות שיהיו נחוצות
להנעת הדור הבא של מכשירים
איך מגיעים לשם? על ידי בניית המכשירים הקוונטיים המתקדמים ביותר בעולם
ופלטפורמת פיתוח
ולהנגיש אותה לעולם
רק על ידי עבודה משותפת עכשיו
נוכל לפתור את הבעיות שנצטרך להתמודד איתן
ביחד בעתיד.